It's been two years since the World Health Organization declared COVID-19 a global pandemic. Sometimes it's hard to believe it's been that long, while on other days it feels even longer. Nearly everyone has lost something over these past two years. Many losses were tragic, especially the deaths of loved ones from COVID-19. But even the smaller losses have added up. Graduations, birthday parties, and weddings that were rescheduled and rescheduled again, and finally canceled. Friends and acquaintances whom you can't see or who have fallen out of touch. People who have lost jobs and businesses and maybe even their confidence in the future.
世界卫生组织宣布新冠疫情为全球大流行病至今已有两年了。有时很难相信已经过去了这么久，而有时又觉得时间过得更慢。在过去的两年里，几乎每个人都失去了一些东西。许多损失是悲剧性的，尤其是因新冠疫情而失去亲人。但即使是那些微小的损失也累积了起来。毕业典礼、生日派对和婚礼被一再推迟，最终还是取消了。那些你无法见面或失去联系的朋友和熟人。那些失去工作、生意，甚至可能失去对未来信心的人们。
Now, after two years and with, we hope, the latest variant receding, many people are hoping yet again to close the book on COVID and move on with regular life. But what if closing the book is an elusive goal? What if closure is not what we should be aiming for? And instead, there's a different way to think about life after loss. What have we learned about grief and resilience and moving on after two years of pandemic life? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Pauline Boss, a professor emerita in the Department of Family Social Service at the University of Minnesota. Dr. Boss coined the term
现在，两年过去了，我们希望最新的变异毒株正在消退，许多人再次希望给新冠疫情画上句号，继续正常生活。但如果“画上句号”是一个难以实现的目标呢？如果“终结”并不是我们应该追求的目标呢？相反，对于失去后的生活，是否有一种不同的思考方式？在经历了两年的大流行生活后，我们对悲伤、韧性和继续前行有了哪些了解？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是明尼苏达大学家庭社会服务系名誉教授宝琳·博斯博士。博斯博士创造了
ambiguous loss in the 1970s. Coming from the discipline of family therapy, she originally implied the term to family's mourning a loved one whose loss was in some way unresolved, like a soldier missing in war. In the years since, she and other researchers have expanded the scope of ambiguous loss, using it as a framework through which to view any number of personal, communal, or global losses, from the pandemic to racial trauma to climate change. Her new book, The Myth of Closure, ambiguous loss in a time of pandemic and change addresses these topics and more. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Boss. It's my pleasure.
“模棱两可的损失”（ambiguous loss）这一术语，时间是在20世纪70年代。她最初将这一术语应用于家庭治疗领域，指代那些因亲人以某种方式处于“未解决”的失踪状态（如战争中失踪的士兵）而哀悼的家庭。此后多年，她和其他研究人员扩展了“模棱两可的损失”的范畴，将其作为一个框架，用以审视各种个人、社区或全球性的损失，从大流行病到种族创伤，再到气候变化。她的新书《终结的神话：大流行与变革时代的模棱两可的损失》探讨了这些话题以及更多内容。感谢您参加我们的节目，博斯博士。这是我的荣幸。
Let's start with the title of your book, The Myth of Closure. Many of us tend to think that we want closure after a death or a divorce or a breakup. Why do you believe that closure is the wrong thing to be looking for after we lose something or someone? Well, closure has a definition meaning finality. It means closing the door on something that has happened. It's a perfectly good word in the business community for closing a contract, for closing a real estate deal, or for closing a road after a flood has occurred. But it is a harmful word in human relationships. It indicates that even though we have had attachment to someone or something like a pet, that once they are gone, we can close the door on that.
让我们从您的书名《终结的神话》开始谈起。我们许多人往往认为，在经历死亡、离婚或分手后，我们想要的是“终结”（closure）。为什么您认为在失去某物或某人后，追求“终结”是错误的方向呢？嗯，“终结”的定义意味着最终性。它意味着对已经发生的事情关上大门。在商业领域，这是一个非常好的词，用于结束合同、完成房地产交易或在洪水发生后封闭道路。但在人际关系中，它是一个有害的词。它暗示着，尽管我们曾与某人或某物（比如宠物）建立了依恋，但一旦他们离开，我们就可以对那段关系关上大门。
That's not true. There are continuing bonds, as has been now declared in the grief literature, and that we don't close the door. We live with loss and grief. Do you think this desire for closure is culture-specific? Is it something that Americans are particularly invested in, or is it even a more universal desire? It's not a universal desire. It is, I think, more American than anywhere else. perhaps because we're a very mass-oriented culture. We believe in fixing things, finding cures. We do that very well, by the way, and we have put people in outer space and helicopters
事实并非如此。正如悲伤文献中所述，存在着“持续的纽带”，我们并不会关上那扇门。我们与失去和悲伤共存。您认为这种对“终结”的渴望是特定于某种文化的吗？这是美国人特别执着的东西，还是一个更普遍的愿望？这不是一个普遍的愿望。我认为，它比在其他任何地方都更具美国特色。这可能是因为我们是一个非常注重结果的文化。我们相信解决问题、寻找疗法。顺便说一句，我们在这方面做得很好，我们已经把人类送入了太空，把直升机
on Mars and a camera into deep space. We are really good at solving problems and precision and fixing things. But now and then something happens in human relationships that can't be fixed, a terminal illness, or in this case, a pandemic, that at first we didn't understand. We couldn't master this enemy that was unseen, the virus. Eventually, by the way, the scientists did master it, which was wonderful. But nevertheless, that virus still lurks out there somewhere. Can't be seen.
送到了火星，把摄像机送到了深空。我们非常擅长解决问题、追求精确和修复事物。但偶尔，人际关系中会发生一些无法修复的事情，比如绝症，或者在这种情况下，一场我们起初并不了解的大流行病。我们无法战胜这个看不见的敌人——病毒。顺便说一句，最终科学家们确实战胜了它，这太棒了。但尽管如此，那种病毒仍然潜伏在某个地方。它是看不见的。
It's very ambiguous. It's an ambiguous enemy. that is still with us. And even when the pandemic is over, it apparently will turn into an endemic, which means the virus will still be here, as is the virus of 1918. Only, we just have an annual flu shot for that. So if not closure, you talked about living with the loss, how do people do that? What's different about saying it's over and done with and saying, this is still with me? Well, the difference. is that what people really want is finality, is clarity. What they really want is certainty about what's going on.
它非常模棱两可。这是一个仍然伴随着我们的“模棱两可的敌人”。即使大流行结束了，它显然也会变成一种地方性流行病，这意味着病毒仍将存在，就像1918年的病毒一样。只是，我们现在有了年度流感疫苗。那么，如果不是“终结”，您谈到了“与失去共存”，人们该如何做到这一点呢？说“一切都结束了”和说“这仍然伴随着我”有什么不同？嗯，区别在于，人们真正想要的是最终性，是清晰度。他们真正想要的是对正在发生的事情有确定性。
I understand that totally. We have a little more certainty now about the pandemic than we had before, thanks to the scientists and the medical people who have learned along the way and who built on previous research, by the way. And so what human beings want is not closure after, loss. What they want is certainty of what that loss was, if it's a human loss or even a pet loss, where the remains are, and that they're not just missing in action. That ambiguity is very, very stressful on top of a loss. In other words, it exaggerates the pain of the loss.
我完全理解这一点。多亏了那些在过程中不断学习并建立在先前研究基础上的科学家和医疗人员，我们现在对大流行病的了解比以前多了一些确定性。所以，人类在失去后想要的不是“终结”。他们想要的是对所失去之物（如果是失去亲人或宠物）的确定性，知道遗体在哪里，而不是仅仅处于“失踪”状态。这种模棱两可的状态在失去本身之上增加了非常、非常大的压力。换句话说，它加剧了失去的痛苦。
It freezes the grief, and it freezes the family processes, the couple and family processes that could go on. No decision-making happens. People wait. And of course, sometimes they wait for decades, which is not functional in families and couples. The family and couples system has to move on without the missing person. And so I recommend both-hand thinking, whereby they both hope for a good outcome, either finding remains or having the person return, they hope for certainty, but they also move forward with their daily lives. It has to be both. It can't be one or the other. So let's talk about the term ambiguous loss, which you coined in the 1970s, in the context of family therapy.
它冻结了悲伤，也冻结了家庭、夫妻本可以继续进行的进程。决策无法做出。人们在等待。当然，有时他们会等待几十年，这在家庭和夫妻关系中是不起作用的。家庭和夫妻系统必须在没有失踪者的情况下继续前行。所以我建议采用“两者兼顾”的思维方式，即他们既希望有一个好的结果，无论是找到遗体还是人能回来，他们希望获得确定性，但他们同时也继续推进日常生活。必须两者兼顾。不能非此即彼。那么，让我们谈谈您在20世纪70年代在家庭治疗背景下创造的“模棱两可的损失”这一术语。
And you define two different types of ambiguous loss, loss in which A loved one is missing physically and loss in which a loved one is missing psychologically. Can you talk about that early work and what led you to study this phenomenon? Well, what led me to study this phenomenon is that when I was studying from my doctorate at the University of Wisconsin and Madison, I was observing Dr. Carl Whitaker in the Department of Psychiatry, who was teaching family therapy at the time. And families would come in with the child as the identified patient. What I noticed was that the fathers were always angry at being there, know that this was the 1970s.
您定义了两种不同类型的模棱两可的损失：亲人在身体上缺失的损失，以及亲人在心理上缺失的损失。您能谈谈那项早期工作以及是什么促使您研究这一现象吗？嗯，促使我研究这一现象的原因是，当我在威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校攻读博士学位时，我观察了当时在精神病学系教授家庭治疗的卡尔·惠特克博士。家庭会带着孩子作为“被认定的患者”前来就诊。我注意到，父亲们总是对来到这里感到愤怒，要知道那是20世纪70年代。
And the fathers would say, why am I here? I should be at my job. The children are mother's business. And so I wrote a paper as a grad student about the psychological absence of the fathers in an intact family. So I was about to study psychological father absence in an intact family. That was my first publication. And meanwhile, I was studying over in sociology, a theory construction. And the professor said, that's a good term psychological absence.
父亲们会说：“我为什么在这儿？我应该在工作。孩子是母亲的事。”所以，作为一名研究生，我写了一篇关于完整家庭中父亲心理缺失的论文。所以我当时正要研究完整家庭中父亲的心理缺失。那是我的第一篇出版物。与此同时，我正在社会学系学习理论构建。教授说：“这是一个很好的术语，‘心理缺失’。”
But it's about more than fathers, Pauline. He said, think about a more general term. And so I went home and pondered about it a long time, but eventually came up with the term ambiguous loss. so it could be anyone in the family. I was studying families at the time, and so I had it at that level that a person could either be physically missing. An extreme example would be soldiers missing in war, loved ones kidnapped. A more common example comes from divorce and adoption and so on, or the person could be
“但这不仅仅是关于父亲，宝琳。”他说，“想一个更通用的术语。”于是我回家思考了很久，最终想出了“模棱两可的损失”这个词。这样它就可以指代家庭中的任何人。我当时正在研究家庭，所以我把它设定在那个层面，即一个人可能在身体上缺失。一个极端的例子是战争中失踪的士兵、被绑架的亲人。一个更常见的例子来自离婚、收养等等，或者那个人可能是
psychologically absent, and the most common use of that now is for caregivers who are taking care of a loved one who has dementia, Alzheimer's disease, or the over 80 other kinds of conditions that cause dementia. But it also could be used for a traumatic brain injury. It could be used for severe depression and other severe mental illnesses. More common examples, of psychological ambiguous loss would be preoccupation with work so that you're not available to your family or your partner. Or it could be the preoccupation with our devices so that, you know, you see a couple at a restaurant having a lovely dinner together and both have their heads in their telephones.
在心理上缺失的，现在最常见的用法是针对那些照顾患有痴呆症、阿尔茨海默病或导致痴呆的80多种其他疾病的亲人的照护者。但它也可以用于创伤性脑损伤。它可以用于严重的抑郁症和其他严重的精神疾病。心理上模棱两可的损失更常见的例子是沉迷于工作，导致你无法陪伴家人或伴侣。或者可能是沉迷于我们的设备，你知道，你在餐馆看到一对夫妇在共进愉快的晚餐，但两人都低头看着手机。
So that's a more common problem right now, I think. So that's how it all got started. And then more recently in the new book, I have raised the ambiguous loss theory to a higher level to include society. And globally, such as the pandemic, caused ambiguous losses for everyone on this world. And then it made me think about racism here because I lived very near to where George Floyd was killed here in Minneapolis. and my eyes were opened with that videotape that that young woman took, Adela Fraser, and for some reason it opened my thinking in a way that should have been open before, but wasn't.
所以我认为这是目前一个更普遍的问题。这就是一切的开始。最近在我的新书中，我将“模棱两可的损失”理论提升到了一个更高的层面，将其涵盖到社会层面。在全球范围内，比如大流行病，给这个世界上的每个人都造成了模棱两可的损失。然后它让我想到了这里的种族主义，因为我就住在乔治·弗洛伊德在明尼阿波利斯被杀的地方附近。那段年轻女子阿德拉·弗雷泽拍摄的录像带让我大开眼界，出于某种原因，它以一种本应早该开启但之前并未开启的方式打开了我的思维。
Perhaps because we were locked in at the time, we were more reflective, I'm not sure what. But at any rate, I believe that across generational transmission of transnational transmission of trauma from slavery started with the ambiguous loss of slavery when families were torn apart on the auction block sold off parents, one from the other, and parents from children. And that that heinous crime of slavery has, in fact, not gone away. That is still the stress and the trauma of it is still with us today. And then I also also. mentioned more as a proposition for other people to study and not me, I propose that climate change is causing ambiguous losses, the loss of clean water, the loss of fertile lands, the loss of
也许是因为当时我们被封锁了，我们更加反思了，我不确定是什么原因。但无论如何，我相信跨代传播的创伤始于奴隶制的模棱两可的损失，当时家庭在拍卖台上被拆散，父母被彼此卖掉，父母与孩子分离。而奴隶制那种令人发指的罪行，事实上并没有消失。那种压力和创伤至今仍伴随着我们。然后我也提到，更多是作为一个供他人研究而非我个人的命题，我提出气候变化正在造成模棱两可的损失，清洁水源的丧失、肥沃土地的丧失、
a life as we knew it. And that will be for future generations to test. We actually did a podcast not long ago about climate change in which we talked to a couple of experts who discussed ecological grief. And I think that's kind of what you're talking about, that you're grieving losses due to what's happening to our environment. How is that connected to the same feelings that we have with respect to, say, the pandemic or racism? Well, again, it's a loss you can't see. When someone dies, at least in normal times, we'd have a funeral, we'd have a ritual, there'd be a notice in the paper, there would be a death certificate, there would be certainty about a loss with death,
我们所熟知的生活方式的丧失。这将留给后代去验证。我们不久前确实做过一期关于气候变化的播客，采访了几位讨论“生态悲伤”的专家。我想这和你所说的是一样的，即你正在为环境变化所导致的损失而悲伤。这与我们在面对大流行病或种族主义时所感受到的相同情绪有何联系？嗯，同样，这是一种你看不见的损失。当有人去世时，至少在正常时期，我们会举行葬礼，会有仪式，报纸上会有讣告，会有死亡证明，死亡带来的损失会有确定性，
but there's also some other losses that have certainty, such as loss of money during the COVID, loss of your retirement savings during COVID, loss of your house during COVID. Those all can be quantified. But I'm talking about losses that have no quantification. They're so uncertain, they're so unclear, that in fact, we don't,
但也有一些其他损失是有确定性的，比如新冠期间金钱的损失、新冠期间退休储蓄的损失、新冠期间房子的损失。这些都可以量化。但我说的是那些无法量化的损失。它们是如此不确定，如此模糊，以至于事实上，我们并没有
list them, or we list them as deaths, as they did in the Civil War and in other wars, they are different because the family has no assurance of death. And now and then a few people came walking out of the jungle, or after 9-11 in New York, a few people were found in psychiatric institutions without remembering what happened to them. What makes this different is that we have all these ambiguous losses that if, happen to us. And so the general population is talking about mental health issues. Come on, there's stress issues. And we're causing, we're calling too much a mental health problem that needs psychiatric help or psychological help. We're pathologizing a normal reaction to an abnormal situation.
列出它们，或者像在内战和其他战争中那样将它们列为死亡，它们是不同的，因为家庭没有死亡的保证。偶尔有几个人从丛林中走出来，或者在纽约9-11事件后，有几个人在精神病院被发现，却不记得发生了什么。使之不同的是，我们都有这些发生在我们身上的模棱两可的损失。所以普通大众在谈论心理健康问题。得了吧，那是压力问题。我们把太多的东西称为需要精神科帮助或心理帮助的心理健康问题。我们正在将对异常情况的正常反应病理化。
I'm going to repeat that. We cannot pathologize normal reactions to a pathological situation. We have just had two years of a pathological situation, literally a pathogen out there where we can't see it, causing many, many deaths, many illnesses, and just uprooting the entire world from what we used to do and how we used to live. We haven't had major loss, but not all the loss was quantifiable. Yet, it is real. So I completely understand the ambiguity of the pandemic and what's been happening to us over the last two years. But when somebody dies, or even if a pet dies, I mean, that's sort of an end point. Isn't that something where we should feel like it's done? Why is that still an ambiguous loss?
我要重复一遍。我们不能将对病态情况的正常反应病理化。我们刚刚经历了两年病态的情况，字面上有一个我们看不见的病原体，导致了许多、许多死亡，许多疾病，并彻底颠覆了整个世界，改变了我们过去做事和生活的方式。我们遭受了重大损失，但并非所有的损失都是可量化的。然而，它是真实的。所以我完全理解大流行病的模糊性以及过去两年发生在我们身上的事情。但当某人去世，甚至如果宠物去世，我的意思是，那算是一个终点。难道那不应该让我们觉得“结束了”吗？为什么那仍然是一个模棱两可的损失？
It feels different to me qualitatively than the other things that you were just talking about. It may be somewhat different, but there is no end point. That is, there's a transformation from breathing to not breathing, from life to death. That's a transformation. And there is no closure on the relationship you had with that person or that pet. Indeed, something has changed. and we need to recognize that. But we'll recognize it more likely if people can differentiate between the physical ending,
我觉得它在性质上与你刚才谈到的其他事情不同。它可能有些不同，但没有终点。也就是说，从呼吸到停止呼吸，从生命到死亡，这是一个转变。对于你与那个人或那只宠物之间的关系，并没有“终结”。确实，有些事情已经改变了。我们需要认识到这一点。但如果人们能够区分身体上的终结，
that is the breathing ends, versus the attachment. So I'm really coming out of attachment theory of Volvey, which says that once you make an attachment to someone or something, I couldn't even talk about someone's home. you make an attachment that even if that thing is no longer with you, if the person has stopped breathing or if you've lost that home or that pet, you can still feel attached to them. You can still say, I love that.
即呼吸停止，与依恋之间的区别，我们更有可能认识到这一点。所以我真的源于鲍尔比的依恋理论，该理论认为，一旦你与某人或某物建立了依恋，我甚至无法谈论某人的家，你建立了一种依恋，即使那个东西不再和你在一起，如果那个人已经停止呼吸，或者你失去了那个家或那只宠物，你仍然可以感到依恋。你仍然可以说：“我爱那个。”
That was my favorite place. I love that person. That was my favorite pet of all times. I love that pet. I miss them. you know they're gone. And so we call that continuing bonds that came first from the edited book by K-L-A-S-S and and other his colleagues, that continuing bonds is what is normal grief. Getting over it is an artificial idea put upon, I think, of the people who are grieving in a culture
“那是我最喜欢的地方。我爱那个人。那是我有史以来最喜欢的宠物。我爱那只宠物。我想念他们。”你知道他们走了。所以我们称之为“持续的纽带”，这首先来自克拉斯（Klass）和他同事编辑的书，即“持续的纽带”才是正常的悲伤。“走出来”是一个强加给悲伤者的虚假观念，我认为，在一个
that has no patience for suffering. We might be that culture. You wrote in your book about your own experience of loss from your early childhood memories of your immigrant father, missing his Swiss homeland, your brother dying of polio as a child, and to your becoming a caretaker for your husband before he died in 2020.
对痛苦没有耐心的文化中。我们可能就是那种文化。你在书中写到了你自己的损失经历，从你童年时期对移民父亲怀念瑞士家乡的记忆，到你弟弟童年时死于小儿麻痹症，再到你在丈夫2020年去世前成为他的照护者。
How have these personal experiences shaped how you think about loss today? from the beginning and the earliest loss was my little brother who died of polio the summer before the SOC vaccine came out. My view already back then was that I didn't have to get over it. But then I was a bit of a rebel right then already. But I lived in a Swiss immigrant community, New Orleans, Wisconsin, where everybody came from, in that case, Switzerland.
这些个人经历是如何塑造你今天对损失的看法的？从一开始，最早的损失是我弟弟，他在索尔克疫苗问世前的那个夏天死于小儿麻痹症。那时我的观点就是，我不必“走出来”。但那时我已经有点叛逆了。但我生活在一个瑞士移民社区，威斯康星州的新奥尔良，每个人都来自那里，在这种情况下是瑞士。
They were all homesick. I lived in an environment of homesickness in the village, but also in my home. So I was kind of accustomed to the fact that you don't cut bonds. You remember them, even though I had the sad version of it, a little heavy on the sadness side, I thought. But therefore, the community, I think, was perhaps advanced at that time in this regard, in that nobody ever told me I should get over it. there was always remembering class reunions would remember my dead brother, his classmates.
他们都患有思乡病。我生活在一个充满思乡之情的村庄环境里，在家里也是如此。所以我习惯了这样一个事实：你不会切断纽带。你会记住他们，尽管我觉得我有悲伤的版本，在悲伤方面有点沉重。但因此，我认为那个社区在当时这方面可能比较先进，因为从来没有人告诉我应该“走出来”。总是会有纪念活动，同学聚会会纪念我死去的弟弟，他的同学们也会。
And so I perhaps was lucky to live in an environment as I was growing up where there was no closure. You remembered people every memorial day. You went to the gravesites and remembered them and so on. Today it's a different story as I live in more urban environment now. and corporate ideas that, you know, we'll give you a week, three days maybe to grieve and then come back and be productive. That assumes you get over it. And the thing is, you don't need to get over it. Even with a clear-cut death, with a death certificate, with funeral after, and all the appropriate rituals,
所以我可能很幸运，在成长过程中生活在一个没有“终结”的环境中。你会在每个阵亡将士纪念日记住人们。你会去墓地纪念他们等等。今天情况不同了，因为我现在生活在更城市化的环境中。以及企业理念认为，你知道，我们会给你一周，也许三天时间去悲伤，然后回来继续保持高效。这假设你已经“走出来”了。问题是，你不需要走出来。即使是明确的死亡，有死亡证明，有葬礼，以及所有适当的仪式，
you don't need to get over it. You can live with grief. and that's recommended. And Bonano and other researchers say, and Nimar say there's oscillation, that it ebbs and flows, grief ebbs and flows, or comes in and out. And over time, those ebbs and flows, oscillations will be farther apart. But they're never gone. There's never closure. So the latest research certainly is in the idea of living.
你也不需要走出来。你可以与悲伤共存，这是值得推荐的。博纳诺和其他研究人员说，尼马尔说存在“振荡”，悲伤会起伏，或者进进出出。随着时间的推移，那些起伏、振荡会变得越来越远。但它们永远不会消失。从来没有“终结”。所以最新的研究肯定在于“与损失共存”的理念，而不是“走出来”。然后在书中，我写到了弗洛伊德事实上在给朋友的私人信件中传达的信息与他在学术著作中传达的信息不同，因为当客户对他说：“我很遗憾你的女儿去世了。”她在1920年死于流感。他说：“不，她还在这里。”他拍了拍他的背心口袋，里面一定有她的纪念品。现在，他从未在学术著作中告诉我们这一点。他谈到了“脱离”，我谈到了更多库布勒-罗斯和其他人，他们学术上写一种方式，个人写另一种方式。
with loss, not getting over it. And then in the book, I write about the fact that Freud, in fact, gave us a different message in his personal letters to his friends than he did in his academic writings because when the client said to him, I'm sorry about your daughter who died. She died of the flu in 1920. And he said, no, she's still here. and he patted his vest pocket, wherein he must have had some momentum of her. Now, he never told us that in his academic writings. He talked about detachment, and I talk about more Kubler-Ross and others who write one way academically and write another way personally.
库布勒-罗斯在生命尽头，在她中风九次之后，抱歉，是多次中风，但活了九年无法行走。她说，死亡并不是那五个阶段，她本意是那样的，它不是线性的，它是混乱的。这对她来说很混乱，她对此感到非常愤怒。所以我们需要重新审视我们历史上的那些在个人著作中改变了想法的阶段。我写这本书更个人化，因为我想确保我在个人和专业上尽可能一致。这令人钦佩。我很感激你讲述那个故事。谢谢。对于许多年轻的美国人来说，大流行病是他们第一次经历生存威胁和大规模的社区损失。
Kubler-Ross in the end of her life after she had nine strokes, many strokes, excuse me, but lived for nine years not being able to. walk. She said that dying was not the five stages, which she meant them to be, that it wasn't linear, that it's messy. And it was messy for her, and she was angry about it a lot. So we need to take another look at our historical stages who changed their minds in their personal writings. And I wrote this book more personally because I wanted to make sure I was congruent personally and professionally as much as I could. That's admirable. I appreciate you telling that story. Thank you. For many younger Americans, the pandemic was their first experience for existential threat and a communal large-scale loss.
现在，前几代人经历了经济大萧条、世界大战。人们过去在生命早期经历的损失要多得多。妇女通常死于分娩，或者儿童死于不再致命的传染病，因为我们有了更好的药物和疫苗。但你认为大流行病改变了当今年轻人对风险、不确定性和损失的看法吗？你认为这会对他们未来处理损失和悲伤的方式产生持久的影响吗？我想是的。现在下结论还为时过早。但我预测，经过这两年的动荡和对我们正常生活方式的颠覆，将会发生变化。我们已经看到了做事方式的变化。我对年轻人充满信心，因为他们比成年人，或者我们越老越有韧性。孩子们也很有韧性。他们会记住这一点，就像我记得
Now, earlier generations live through a major depression, world wars. People used to experience much more loss a lot earlier in life. Women commonly died in childbirth or children died of communicable diseases that are no longer fatal because we have much better medicine and vaccines. But do you think that the pandemic has changed the way that the younger people today are thinking about risk, uncertainty, and loss? And do you think this will have lasting effects about how they approach loss and grief going forward? I think so. It's too soon to tell. But I predict there is going to be change as a result of this two years of turmoil and upheaval into our normal way of life. We already see changes and how we do things. And I have great faith in young people for being resilient, more resilient than adults. are or the older we get. And children are resilient too. They will remember this as I remembered
小儿麻痹症流行一样，就像我记得大萧条一样，就像我作为一个孩子记得第二次世界大战一样。我感到害怕，通过观察父母的脸，我会知道该有多害怕。但在某种程度上，那教会了我们什么，以及现在将教会年轻人什么，我认为，是你不能总是如愿以偿。你不能总是让世界按照你想要的方式运转。有悲剧。有困难时期。你知道吗？我们可以度过难关。我认为今天的年轻人可能会学到的是，他们度过了难关。好的。我和不少错过了大学毕业典礼、在没有说再见的情况下立即与朋友断绝联系的人谈过，等等，等等。
the polio epidemic, as I remembered the Depression, and as I remembered World War II as a child. I was afraid by watching my parents' faces, I would know how afraid to be. But in a way, what that taught us and what will teach the young people now, I think, is that you can't always have your way. You can't always have the world be the way you want it to be. There are tragedies. There are difficult times. And you know what? We can get through them. And I think what young people today may learn is that they got through this. Okay. I talked to quite a few of them who missed college graduations who were cut off from friends immediately without saying bye, et cetera, et cetera.
但他们对此有一种我发现非常成熟的哲学回应。他们找到了其他方式与无法在现实中告别的朋友告别。他们知道他们未来可能会有我们所有人参加过的最好的同学聚会。他们变得更强大了。因为这个。也许我谈论的这一代人，这是他们第一次遇到事情不顺心的时候，对他们中的许多人来说。当然，也有例外。
But they have a philosophic response to it that I find very mature. They found other ways to say goodbye to friends. They couldn't say goodbye to in reality. That they know they will have probably the best class reunions any of us have ever had down the line. They got stronger. because of it. And perhaps this generation I'm talking about, this is the first thing when things didn't go right for them, for many of them. Of course, there were exceptions.
我意识到了这一点。但我们有一段时间的育儿风格，我相信这干扰了年轻人压力管理的发展，父母会确保他们的孩子不感到痛苦。嗯，感到压力并能够应对它会教会你，你比你想象的要强大。这对你余生来说是非常宝贵的一课。我可以在现在的许多年轻人身上看到这一点。他们会因此变得更强大。并不是我希望任何人经历这些，但一旦逆境发生，而你在其中表现出韧性，你像风暴中的树一样弯曲，但你又站了起来。你在经历这些之后，在心理上会变得更强大。
I realized that. But we've had a parenting style for a while that, that I believe has interfered with the stress management development of the young people, whereby parents would make sure their kids weren't distressed. Well, being stressed and being able to cope with it teaches you that you are stronger than you think. And that's a very valuable lesson for the rest of your life. And I can see that in many of the young people now. They will be stronger for it. Not that I wish this on anyone, but once adversity happens and you were resilient in it, you bent like a tree and a storm, but you got up again. You are stronger psychologically for having been through that.
那么，在你的职业生涯中写下并观察了这么多关于悲伤和损失的内容后，你认为自己基本上是一个乐观主义者还是悲观主义者？哦，我是个乐观主义者。我不认为自己是悲伤专家，因为那样的专家太多了。我认为自己是损失和损失细微差别的专家，是不同种类的损失及其造成的压力的专家。我从压力领域开始，这本质上是我的出身。模棱两可的损失不是一种关注病理的医学模型。它是一种关注韧性的压力模型。因此，并且来自一个在大萧条时期经历过艰难困苦的家庭，然后，正如我所说，第二次世界大战，看到人们在之后站起来。顺便说一句，这些都是可怕的事情。现在有了大流行病，我再次看到人们以一种比我以前见过的更成熟的方式，特别是在年轻人身上。
So after writing and observing so much about grief and loss during your career, do you consider yourself basically an optimist or a pessimist about the human condition? Oh, I'm an optimist. And I don't consider myself a grief expert because there's so many of them. I consider myself an expert on loss and the nuances of loss, the different kinds of loss and the stress it causes. I started out in the stress field and that's essentially where I come from. Ambiguous loss is not a medical model focused on pathology. It's a stress model focused on resilience. As a result of that, And having come from a family of hard times during the Depression and then, as I said, World War II, and seeing people, you know, stand up after that. And these were terrible things, by the way. And now with the pandemic, again, I see people in a way that they have more maturity than I've ever seen before, in the young people especially.
在其他人身上，他们以非常有创造力的方式应对。确实，有些人没有，因为有些人相信二元思维。当然，大流行病的科学，科学从来不是二元的。它总是基于概率。他们想要一个干净的答案。他们想要“终结”。我处于危险之中吗？我戴口罩还是不戴？
And in other people, they've coped in very creative ways. Indeed, some have not because some people believe in binary thinking. And, of course, the science of the pandemic, science is never binary. It's always based on probability. And they wanted a clean answer. They wanted closure. Am I in danger or not? Do I wear a mask or do I not?
病毒是真的还是假的？所以我们看到一部分人口需要绝对的思维，更像是“终结”。他们进行二元思考，你知道，你要么和我在一起，要么不在一起。要么死，要么活。要么安全，要么不安全。那种思维方式现在行不通。顺便说一句，这些人不是乐观主义者。所以我认为如果你能以一种更有韧性的方式思考，如果你能以一种更有韧性的方式行动，
Is the virus real or is it not? So we saw a part of the population that needs absolute thinking, more like closure. They think in binaries, you know, you're either with me or you're not. It's either dead or alive. It's either safe or it's not safe. That way of thinking didn't work right now. And these are not optimists, by the way. So I think if you can think in a more resilient way, if you can act in a more resilient way,
如果你能以一种更有韧性的方式行动，灵活变通，但从中学习，每次都变得更强大，你也会变得乐观，因为这意味着你可以应对生活中出现的几乎任何事情，亲人的死亡、事故、失业。我并不希望任何人经历这些，但顺便说一句，死亡是不可避免的。如果只是你的父母变老并最终去世。所以生活会带来损失。我们练习保持韧性将会得到回报。正如我在书中写的那样，它会让我们知道，
if you can act in a more resilient way, flexible, but learning from it, growing stronger each time, you will also be optimistic because what that means is you can cope with most anything that comes along in life, the death of your loved ones, accidents, loss of a job. I don't wish that on anyone, but by the way, death is inevitable. if only it's your parents getting older and eventually dying. And so life will bring its losses. And our practice with being resilient will pay off. It will let us know, as I wrote in the book,
你可以被打倒，但你可以再次站起来。好吧，博斯博士，我认为这是一个美妙的希望信息。我很感激你今天把它带给我们的听众。我希望他们学到了一些东西，这将帮助他们度过这些艰难的时期，我认为这对我们许多人来说都很困难。所以感谢你今天加入我们。我的荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集
you can be knocked down, but you can get up again. Well, Dr. Boss, I think that's a wonderful message of hope. I appreciate your bringing it to our listeners today. I hope that they have learned some things that will help them through these trying times, which I think have been difficult for many of us. So thank you for joining us today. My pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org
或者在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方。如果你在 Apple 上收听，请给我们留下评论。如果你有对未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康达扬。感谢收听。
or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you listen on Apple, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. that's Speaking of Psychology all one word at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening.
代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。